PEGI 18 we developed and remastered the
critically acclaimed Hong Kong open
world action experience Sleeping Dogs is
back with a new generation in the
definitive edition
you were way Shen a member of the Sun on
Yi and one of the most feared and
respected triads in the city you must be
a very dangerous man raishin you're also
a highly skilled undercover cop that is
exactly what we want people to think
with new advanced hardware fine-tuned
gameplay action and upgraded visuals and
audio Sleeping Dogs definitive edition
is more immersive and impressive ever
before I am doing what needs to be done
though you've crossed the line it's on
the streets of Hong Kong where you'll
make a name for yourself
Oh dazzle with the definitive edition
you'll be experiencing Sleeping Dogs the
way it was meant to be in full native
1080p high definition resolution
utilizing the powerful Hardware of new
generation consoles advanced lighting
and atmospheric effects improved models
and extensive texture improvements have
been applied across the city making Hong
Kong more beautiful and realistic than
ever before Oh relax man it's way plus
the added boost of power also allows for
heavier traffic and more pedestrians
giving the open-world big city chaos of
the definitive edition of personality
and life of its own time to move up in
the world with the
improvements Hong Kong becomes more than
a location it becomes its own character
you look like you could use a pork bun
definitive edition means just that
definitive pact with all the extra
downloadable and bonus content
previously released on consoles
including all the stories missions moves
weapons and vehicles seems you made a
lot of bosses unhappy lately
this is insane renewed and redeveloped
remastered the critically acclaimed hit
is back with upgraded visuals enhanced
gameplay and a massive array of content
in a colossal definitive edition it's
time to experience Sleeping Dogs
like never before
you